I'm elected to make these decisions I'll
make the decisions I'll make it in time
for Brian Wilson of Scotch Plains New
Jersey confronted Governor Chris
Christie at a campaign stop in his
hometown challenging the governor to
provide a reason for his delay in
signing a bill that would make it
possible for his two-year-old daughter
vivianne who suffers from a devastating
form of epilepsy to receive the medical
marijuana she was prescribed Vivian has
a very severe form of epilepsy called
dravet syndrome she started having
seizures as a baby just two months old
her first year of life she would cease
anywhere from like 25 minutes to an hour
every time she had a seizure medical
marijuana has been legal in New Jersey
for three and a half years but governor
Christie's Department of Health has made
it nearly impossible for patients to
obtain in the Garden State and it is
completely impossible for patients to
receive the kind of cannabis that would
help Vivien which is a high CBD low THC
form that has none of the psychoactive
effects of marijuana that is it can't
get you high the biggest benefit to
these high CBD meds is seizure control
children are having significant
reduction in seizures I'm talking
anywhere from 90 to 100 percent in June
the New Jersey State Legislature passed
a reform minded medical marijuana bill
which dropped the number of doctors
required to sign off on a prescription
from three to one repealed the ban on
edible forms of medicinal marijuana and
removed the limit on dispensaries from
growing more than one strain the last
two reforms are vital to Vivian because
as a two-year-old edibles are her only
realistic option and because the three
strain limit made growing the less
popular low THC strain that she needs a
man started for the one functioning
dispensary in New Jersey by August the
bill had been sitting unsigned on
governor Christie's desk for more than
two months people are suffering while
this bill is sitting on his desk I
really wanted to know what was taking so
long
I wish for the best for you your
daughter and your family I'm going to do
what I think is best for the people of
the state after video of the dust-up in
the diner went viral
Governor Christie agreed to sign a
compromised form of the bill allowing
for edibles from minors only this
compromise still adversely affects
Vivian because limiting edibles to
minors artificially decreases demand
making it less likely that a dispensary
would make the investment in opening a
kitchen and enduring all the red tape
involved to produce edible forms of
marijuana for an extremely limited
consumer base and despite the fact that
medical marijuana is legal in 20 states
the federal government still lists
marijuana as a schedule 1 drug making it
a felony to bring it across state lines
even for medicinal purposes part of the
problem were so hesitant to just moved
to Colorado because once we're in
Colorado we can't leave Colorado we can
never come home for a holiday I mean
you're trapped in your state this is
life and death for Vivian and I don't
say that lightly I mean it children
would travail syndrome die
they do I think 85% make it to adulthood
which is just the age of 18 Vivian has
had seizures that lasted an hour long
she stopped breathing she's been
resuscitated children when travail
syndrome are also at high risk for SUDEP
sudden unexplained death and epilepsy
Vivian has to sleep with a monitor on
her toe that measures her heart rate her
oxygen saturation our lives are devoted
to keeping Vivian alive
really if this doesn't pan out in New
Jersey we will go to Colorado because
this is her life and and we're not gonna
take any more chances in New Jersey you
know just sit back waiting and waiting
and waiting chris christie has made
himself into a national figure by
projecting a plain speaking and
defiantly independent persona but in his
opposition to his own state's law
permitting medical marijuana is he
simply pandering to the National
Republican base in preparation for a
2016 run for president I meant what I
said when I said please don't let my
daughter die politics should not be
determining whether or not children live